[Música]
rusia presentó a occidente de su lista
de exigencias en materia de seguridad
con miras a poner fin a las tensiones
con ucrania el kremlin promete renunciar
a cualquier actividad militar pero con
condiciones a la otan le exige no
aceptar el ingreso de ucrania a la
alianza y eeuu restringir el despliegue
de armas nucleares en el extranjero
nuevos reveses para boris johnson en el
reino unido- su partido perdió un escaño
parlamentario dominado hace casi 200
años por los conservadores los liberales
demócratas se quedaron con el asiento
del norte searcher que quien uno que uno
de los tories había dejado vacante tras
un escándalo de corrupción
hoy hace 10 años kim jong-un se
convirtió en el líder de corea del norte
una de las dinastías más antiguas del
mundo tras la muerte de su padre kim
jong-il mientras la comunidad
internacional critica su carrera
armamentística el polémico mandatario
preside este viernes multitudinarias
conmemoraciones en la capital
gracias por continuar con nosotros este
es un nuevo informativo de france 24 les
habla daniel hablando comenzamos
hablando de la crisis entre rusia y
ucrania el gobierno de vladímir putin
puso sobre la mesa una serie de
propuestas a occidente ligadas a su
seguridad con miras a desescalar las
crecientes tensiones con kiev a el
ministerio de asuntos exteriores público
las propuestas con las que quiere
alcanzar acuerdos con eeuu y con la otan
entre las garantías requeridas por moscú
figuran la prohibición de adhesión a la
alianza atlántica de estados que
formaron parte de la unión soviética
como ucrania frenar la expansión de la
otan hacia los países del este y con
eeuu se propone que ambas partes
renuncien al despliegue de armas
nucleares fuera de las fronteras
nacionales la otan asegura haber
recibido las propuestas pero también
impone condiciones
uy si hemos recibido las recientes
propuestas de rusia somos claros en que
cualquier diálogo con rusia también
tendría que atender las preocupaciones
de la otan sobre las acciones rusas
estar basado en los principios
fundamentales y los documentos de la
seguridad europea y realizarse en
consultas con los socios europeos de la
otan como ucrania los aliados de la otan
también han dejado en claro que si rusia
toma pasos concretos para reducir las
tensiones estamos preparados para
trabajar en fortalecer las medidas para
construir confianza we are better work
constraints incumplan spalding meses
seguimos en europa en reino unido el
escaño parlamentario del norte charter
había estado en manos de conservadores
desde 1830 pero el viernes el partido
liberaldemócrata derrotó al conservador
de boris johnson en una sorprendente
victoria se trata del más reciente en
una serie de reveses para el premier
jour
en una victoria histórica el partido
liberaldemócrata ganó el viernes un
escaño parlamentario en las elecciones
parciales del norte shop sigue asentando
el golpe en un bastión conservador que
se mantuvo durante casi 200 años la
nueva diputada helen morgan se impuso
con un 34% diferencia sobre su ponente
teoría esta noche los habitantes del
norte de churchill han hablado en nombre
del pueblo británico han dicho alto y
claro boris johnson se acabó la fiesta
su gobierno basado en mentiras y
fanfarronadas tendrá que rendir cuentas
será examinado será cuestionado y puede
y será derrotado es la segunda pérdida
de un escaño tory a manos del partido
liberaldemócrata desde julio y los
conservadores dicen que reflexionarán
sobre ello llevamos 11 años de gobierno
conservador nuestras elecciones nunca
son algo fácil pero por supuesto tenemos
que reflexionar sobre el resultado y
estoy seguro de que como partido lo
haremos
la derrota culmina una semana de reveses
para oris johnson a principios de esta
semana el primer ministro sufrió la
mayor rebelión de su mandato desde que
empezó a ejercer su cargo cuando casi
100 miembros de su propio partido
votaron en contra de las nuevas
restricciones para el coronavirus que él
consideraba necesarias las medidas
finalmente se aprobaron solo gracias al
apoyo del opositor partido laborista lo
que abrió la pregunta de si johnson
había perdido el control de los
conservadores el líder británico también
está en la mira por una costosa reforma
de su residencia en downing street y por
las supuestas fiestas navideñas del
gobierno mientras se decreta una
estricta cuarentena a nivel nacional en
2020 también se ha enfrentado a críticas
por su gestión de la pandemia ya que el
reino unido- lucha actualmente contra
una ola de la variante omicron y tiene
una de las mayores cifras de muertos en
todo el mundo
y en corea del norte kim jong-un cumple
10 años en el poder el líder de una de
las dinastías más antiguas del mundo se
mostró como un reformador pero los
disidentes al régimen afirman que es tan
duro como su padre kim jong-il
ampliamente criticado por la comunidad
internacional las pruebas
armamentísticas de la nación asiática
contrastan con las precariedades
sufridas por su pueblo
se le consideraba menos rígido más
abierto occidente pero al igual que
bashar al asad en siria está claro que
la juventud de una breve estancia en
europa no son suficientes para convertir
a los hijos de los dictadores en grandes
demócratas en corea del norte kim
jong-un que celebra su décimo
aniversario en el poder ha demostrado
ser al menos tan duro como su padre kim
jong-il a quien los ciudadanos han
llegado a rendir un homenaje no siempre
espontáneo en uno de los regímenes más
represivos del mundo y lo que más al
estar aquí en la colina de manzur y ver
la imagen de nuestro gran general kim
jong-il con su sonrisa no puede evitar
que se me salgan las lágrimas
del viejo dicho dice que el tiempo pasa
y todo cambia pero aunque el tiempo pase
seguimos echando de menos a nuestro
general humilde lloran como invitado al
disparar repetidamente misiles para
probar el arsenal de corea del norte y
suponer una amenaza para la región
el líder autoritario kim jong-un se ha
ganado el apodo de hombre cohete las
esperanzas de cambio ya no convencen a
muchos expertos
cuando se observa la última década con
kim jong-un en el poder para garantizar
su seguridad es muy probable que corea
del norte siga esgrimiento tanto la
zanahoria como el garrote con falsas
conversaciones de paz y con esta
estrategia de brinkmann psíquico juzgar
con profundidad los tres encuentros con
el expresidente estadounidense donald
trump han sido a juicio de observadores
una ilusión y el brote de kobe 19 ha
sido desde entonces una formidable
excusa para que kim jong-un cierra aún
más corea del norte donde amenazan la
hambruna y los controles fronterizos
especialmente estrictos cada vez son
menos los disidentes que logran salir
del país
y en sudáfrica mientras el presidente de
cyril ramaphosa se recupera del hobbit
19 las autoridades de salud creen que el
impacto de la variante de omicron será
más moderado el ministerio de salud oa
seguridad aseguró que la nueva ola
impulsada por el nuevo linaje podría ser
más leve gracias a un relativamente alto
nivel de inmunidad alcanzado en olas
anteriores por los contagios con el
virus así como por el avance de la
vacunación aunque la cifra supera a
varios países del continente del 44 por
ciento de adultos inmunizados está muy
por debajo del objetivo del gobierno y
de la media mundial
sólo en términos de los números de
muertes estamos empezando a ver un leve
aumento en los fallecimientos a nivel
nacional pero de nuevo este nivel es
mucho más bajo que el periodo base que
tuvimos entre la segunda y la tercera
ola en noticias de américa latina' los
dos candidatos chilenos tuvieron el
jueves en su último acto de campaña
antes de la reñida segunda vuelta
presidencial del próximo domingo el
izquierdista gabriel boric tiene ventaja
en los sondeos pero el ultraderechista
josé antonio kast e fue el vencedor de
la la vuelta informa lluís muñoz
se acerca el desenlace presidencial en
chile una cita clave pero para muchos
chilenos un tema menor como demuestra el
más de 52% de abstencionistas de la
primera vuelta así lo analizó para
france24 marta lagos directora del
latinobarómetro sería la primera vez que
visualizamos la posibilidad de que vote
menos gente que en la segunda vuelta que
en la primera vuelta en medio de este
clima a las tres principales encuestas
dan como vencedor al ex líder
estudiantil izquierda gabriel boric
opinión que comparte marta lagos hay hoy
día un ambiente electoral un ánimo no
selecto de que boris tendría
posibilidades altas de ganar el día el
día domingo este jueves además ambos
candidatos vivieron sus cierres de
campaña el ultraderechista josé antonio
kast escogió la capital santiago cas
venció la primera vuelta con el 27 9% de
los votos pero ha querido centrar su
discurso final en su rival porque eso lo
que conoce la izquierda usar la
violencia como herramienta política y
nosotros no se lo vamos a permitir nunca
más nos vamos a rendir frente a la
intolerancia a la izquierda desde
casablanca comuna de valparaíso boliche
optó por una estrategia bien distinta y
continúa con su tendencia de las últimas
semanas de mostrarse como un candidato
de unidad
somos herederos
las luchas del pueblo de chile
somos herederos de lo que cayeron
luchando por una sociedad distinta y hoy
día no solo excesivo con mucha humildad
aquí estamos para hacer esos sueños
realidad moritz se acercó en la primera
vuelta a la ola del estallido social de
chile de 2019 mientras que en esta
segunda vuelta ha buscado ampliar sus
bases y tras recibir apoyos como el de
la ex presidenta michelle bachelet ha
conseguido tomar una ligera ventaja
así finalizamos este informativo gracias
por su sintonía
[Música]